Special Afferents of the
Head and Neck, Video 2,
Cranial Nerve 2, Vision
This is, by far,
the most important
special afferent
that we have.
Around 30-60% of
our brain is devoted
to processing
visual information.
The optic nerve
is similar to
the olfactory
nerve in that
it is also not
really a nerve.
As with our
olfactory stalks,
the optic nerve
is actually an
anterior extension
of the brain.
The optic nerve travels
rostrally in the
anterior cranial fossa
before exiting the
endocranium through
the optic canal. The
nerve ends in a large
evagination more
affectionately known
as the eyeball. That's
right, our eyes are
both special afferent
organs and the terminal
nerves of the optic
nerve. The eyeball can
be divided into three
layers, a fibrous
layer, a vascular layer,
and a neural layer.
The fibrous layer
of the eye consists
of the outside of the
eyeball itself. This
is called the sclera.
Anterior to the eyeball
is a specialized
part of the sclera
called the cornea.
The anterior portion
of the eye is housed
within an extraocular
compartment known
as the conjunctival
layer. This compartment
serves to hold and
moisten the eye.
Both the sclera and the
cornea are comprised
of the same collagen
fibers. The only
difference is that in
the sclera, all the
collagen fibers are
arranged in this helter
-skelter pattern,
resulting in the fibers
blocking all incoming
lights. In the cornea,
these same fibers
are all arranged
parallel to each other,
allowing light to
pass through the
translucent fibers and
into the eye. The
sclera is tough,
protecting structures
inside the eye and
blocking out light
from other directions.
It also serves as
the distal attachment
for all six of the
extraocular muscles.
The cornea is the window
for light to enter
in the eye. The fibers
of the cornea are
misaligned just enough
to block out the high
energy photons such
as those from most
ultraviolet rays. It
also acts as the main
refractor of light for
the eye. More on that in
a minute. Blood flow to
the sclera is sparse,
and the cornea
itself is completely
avascular, relying on
capillary beds, lacrimal
fluids, and aqueous
humor to bring nutrients
to the cells of the
cornea. Lastly, the
cornea is highly sensitive
to touch. The second
layer of the eye is
the vascular layer.
This consists of
the iris, ciliary
body, and the
choroid. The iris is
the most noticeable
part of the eye.
It lies just
anterior to the lens.
It makes the
color of the eyes,
and it is responsible for
changing the size
of the pupil.
The iris is comprised
of two different
muscles that form
a ring around the
pupil. The innermost
portion of the iris
houses the
constrictor muscle for
the pupil, known as
sphincter pupillae.
This is a ring of
smooth muscle that
is circularly arranged
around the pupil
and when contracted,
will shrink the
size of the pupil. It
is parasympathetically
innervated.
In this image,
sphincter pupillae is
partially covered by
another muscle, the
dilator pupillae.
This is a ring of
radially arranged smooth
muscle fibers that,
when contracted,
pull open the eye
equally from all
directions, resulting
in dilation.
the dilator pupillae is
sympathetically driven.
Now, due to the
radial orientation of
the muscle fibers,
the dilator pupillae
takes longer to contract
than its counterpart,
sphincter pupillae.
Or to put it
another way, you can
constrict your eyes
a lot faster than
you can dilate them.
Posterior to these
muscles is a very thin
layer of pigmented
epithelium. Iris
color is determined by
the amount of melanin
granules produced
by melanocytes in
this pigmented
epithelium. These cells
produce melanin, which
gets trapped between
the fibers of the
two iris muscles.
The more melanin
produced, the darker the
eyes are. Brown eyes
carry the most melanin
in their pigmented
epithelium, whereas green,
hazel, and blue represent
decreasing amounts
of melanin in that
pigmented epithelial
layer. The iris also
serves as a landmark,
demarcating the
end of the anterior
compartment of the eye.
The anterior compartment
of the eye contains
aqueous humor, which
maintains pressure
inside the eye and
helps distribute
nutrients to the cornea.
The ciliary body lies
posterior to the iris.
It is a muscular
ring located at the
corneoscleral junction.
The ciliary body is the
attachment site for
the lens, and it is
responsible for the
production of aqueous
humor in the anterior
compartment of the eye.
The lens is attached
to the ciliary body via
a collection of fibers
known as zonular
fibers, or the zonule
of Zinn, which sounds
like a Lord of the
Rings or Game of Thrones
character. When the
ciliary body is at rest,
the zonular fibers are
taut and pull on the
lens, changing its
shape by making it
thinner and straighter.
When the ciliary body
contracts, the zonular
fibers loosen and the
lens bounces back to
its natural biconvex
shape. This changing of
lens shape is important
for accommodation,
which will be covered
a little later in this
video. The ciliary
body receives
parasympathetic innervation.
The final layer of
the vascular layer is
the choroid. It
comprises the majority of
the posterior compartment
of the eye and is
the main source of
sustenance for structures
inside the eyeball.
It is a dark,
reddish-brown layer. The
red in red-eye pictures
from cameras is the
choroid reflecting
back through the lens.
The choroid consists
of an extremely dense
mesh of capillaries
that deliver nutrient
-rich blood to the
retina. The choroid
is tightly attached
to the posterior part
of the retina, but
only loosely attached
to the anterior part.
Attachment is
maintained by pressure
produced by the
vitreous humor, which is
a gelatinous mass
that fills up most of
the posterior
compartment of the eye.
The innermost layer of
the eye is the neural
layer, and it consists
of the retina. The
retina houses around
150 million different
neurons, and it can be
divided into a neural
layer, again, where the
light-sensitive rods
and cones reside, and
a pigmented layer that
helps reduce the
scatter of light around
the photoreceptors of
the retina. Due to a
fluke of our embryology,
the neural layer of
the fetal retina in humans
and other vertebrates
differentiates
backwards. The light
-sensitive rods and cones
lie deep to the bipolar
interstitial neurons
and ganglionic cells,
which are in direct
line of sight of the
light rays. This means
light has to pass through
this mesh of extra,
non-light-sensitive
material before it hits
our photoreceptors.
For comparison,
the convergently
evolved eyes of
cephalopods, such as
octopus and squid, have
their photoreceptors
arranged the opposite
way, so they are
the first structures
to come in contact
with light rays.
This roundabout way
of getting light
information back to the
brain has produced two
important anatomical
structures within
the eye. One structure
can be seen at the
convergence of all the
neurons of the optic
nerve. This is called
the optic disc, and
it is so dense with
neurons that light
cannot effectively
********* it, resulting
in no photoreceptors
being placed there.
This forms a
blind spot in our
eye. To offset
this, our brains
incorporate some
post-production
trickery to fill
in that blind spot.
On the opposite
end is the macula
lutea. This is a
small depression in
the neural layer
formed by the sloping
of the non
-photoreceptor cells away
from the angle of
incoming light.
At the center of
the macula lutea,
the sloping of the
non-photoreceptive
cells produces
the most direct
access to light for
our photoreceptors,
resulting in the
clearest vision.
This area is called the
fovea or fovea centralis.
Here we see a
histological
slice through the fovea.
Even though most of
the non-photoreceptive
cells have been
pushed to the
side, there is still
a hefty amount of
non-photoreceptive
mesh to cut through
before reaching
these photoreceptors.
Whenever you focus
on an object, you
turn your eye towards
it so that the
image of the object
hits your fovea.
This behavior is
called foveation.
Both of these ocular
structures can
be viewed with an
ophthalmoscope.
The optic disc will
always pop out,
whereas the macula,
because there are
no blood vessels
directly in it, will
often look like a
faint, dark disc.
An important function
of the eyes is the
ability to change the
focal point based on where
an object is in three
-dimensional space.
This is called
accommodation.
To get a focused
image on the back
of our eyes, light
rays need to be bent
into focus as they
enter the eye.
This is done
via refraction.
Light refraction in
the eye is a two-part
process that starts
when light passes
through the cornea. The
cornea is the largest
contributor to
refraction in the eye.
It is responsible
for two-thirds of the
bending of light rays
to focus an image.
The remaining one
-third comes from the
lens, which fine
-tunes the image to
hit the back of the
eyes just right.
The lens by itself is
spherical and elastic.
To adjust the
focal point of the
eyes, the lens
must be deformed.
Objects that are far
away reflect parallel
light rays. To focus
on them, the lens needs
to be stretched and
made thinner. This
reduces its refractive
power, allowing only
for a slight bend to
incoming light rays.
This action is
largely done passively
as the tension of
the zonular fibers
pulls on the lens,
thinning it out.
Objects that are close
to the eye reflect
divergent light rays,
requiring a wider lens
to more strongly bend
the light into focus.
This is an active
process from our eyes,
as parasympathetic
innervation from the
oculomotor nerve,
via the short ciliary
nerves, is required
to stimulate
contraction of the
ciliary body and loosen
the zonular fibers,
allowing the lens to
return to its normal,
spherical shape.
And this is
the part where
it gets counterintuitive.
Because the act
of changing the
lens shape is
a passive one.
No nerve stimulation
is required to
focus on objects
in the distance.
In contrast,
returning the lens to
its normal spherical
shape requires
the eye to contract
the ciliary body
and loosen those
zonular fibers.
This is why our
eyes get tired
after reading or
staring at a screen
for a long time.
the ciliary body
has been contracted
for too long.
Since light typically
travels in a straight
line and the retina
covers the entire
back half of our
spherical eye, our retina
and vision are actually
broken into two
hemispheres per eye.
The retina is divided
into a temporal
hemiretina that covers
the side of the eye
closest to the temporal
bones and a nasal
hemiretina that covers
the side of the eye
closest to the nose.
This divides our
visual field into a
temporal visual field
that covers the half
of our vision closest
to the side of
our face, and a nasal
visual field that
covers light rays
coming closer to the
nose. You will go
into much more detail
on vision later
during neuroanatomy.
For now, the big takeaway
from this picture
is that each hemiretina
receives light
input from the opposite
visual field. For
example, the nasal visual
field will send light
rays to the temporal
hemiretina, and vice
versa. If you find
yourself confused by
this, remember to view
light rays as traveling
in straight lines, and
just draw a straight
line into the eye
from any visual angle.
Neurons from each
hemiretina travel
back to the brain
differently. While
all the optic neurons
pass through this
junction, called
the optic chiasm,
only the neurons
from our nasal
hemiretinas cross
over, or decasate,
at the chiasm,
and then travel to
the contralateral
side of the brain.
Again, this is a
relatively brief summary
of vision. You will
learn much more
about this in neuroanatomy
next semester.
Clinical correlate.
As our most important
special sense, there
are no shortage of
clinical correlates for
vision. By far the most
common is simply the
effects of age. As
we age, our lenses
lose their elasticity,
making it harder for
the lens to bounce back
to its original,
spherical shape, which is
necessary for looking
at close-up objects.
Even though we use
muscular contraction to
look at objects that are
close up, the contraction
only loosens the
attachments of the
zonular fibers. There is
no way for our body to
force our lens to
return to its original
shape once that elasticity
has started to go.
We've all seen
parents, grandparents,
and professors do
the pull-object
-away-from-face
technique to read the
words. This is a
behavioral adjustment
for the reduced
close-up vision.
Treatment is
typically glasses or
contacts, with the
relatively new ability
to use multifocal
presbylasic as a way
to change the
cornea's refractive
ability to accommodate
the stiffer lens.
As with the rest
of the body,
the lens is
comprised of cells.
Normal wear and tear
causes the breakdown of
proteins in these cells.
As we age, the rate
of repair to these
denatured proteins starts
to diminish, resulting
in the lens thickening
with what amounts
to cellular garbage.
Eventually, this
thickening can lead
to a cloudiness
called a cataract. If
left untreated,
the cataract will
eventually cause
blindness as it diffuses
more and more light
across the retina.
Cataracts can be
exacerbated by other
underlying
problems such as
hypertension, poor
nutrition, and smoking.
Cataracts also have
a strong genetic
component to them
and can be brought
on by other congenital
disorders such
as Down syndrome or
Turner's syndrome.
In all cases, cataracts
require surgical
intervention to fix.
This is usually done via
a partial or total lens
replacement depending
on the degree of
cataract cloudiness.
In a healthy person,
aqueous humor is
continuously produced
by the ciliary
body and distributed
across the anterior
chamber of the
eye where it will
drain from the
scleral venous sinus,
which is otherwise known
as the canal of Schlem.
Aqueous humor is
important for proper
nutrition to the
cornea, and when that
flow pattern gets
blocked, the humor can
start to stagnate
and become cloudy.
This cloudiness is
called glaucoma,
and it's usually
caused by a
blockage of that
drainage system.
There are two common
forms of glaucoma.
Open-angled glaucoma
has the scleral venous
sinus blocked by some
of the trabecular
meshwork comprising
the canal itself.
This can lead to a
slow-forming glaucoma.
The second form
is called closed
-angle glaucoma,
and it is caused by
the angle between
the iris and scleral
venous sinus
being too acute.
blocking access to
the canal entirely.
Closed angle glaucoma
is usually more of
a medical emergency
than open angle as
the pressure buildup
happens a lot faster.
Finally, we have
retinal detachment.
Remember that the
retina forms two layers,
a pigmented layer
next to and tightly
adhered to the choroid,
and a neural layer
that has the
photoreceptors on it. The
neural layer is not
tightly adhered and
requires constant
pressure from the aqueous
and vitreous humor
to maintain contact
with the capillary
bed of the choroid.
Any type of eye
damage that reduces
intraocular pressure
puts the retina at risk.
Patients who suffer
retinal detachment
complain of flashes
of light or of
constant specks of
light in their vision.
Retinal detachment is
considered a medical
emergency as the
neural layer of the
retina is very
intolerant of hypoxia
and cell death can
happen very quickly.
This brings us to
the end of video two.